みなさんこんにちは
登壇者の中に女子が少ないということでたくさんの登壇者の中に急遽挟んでいただき
ました安田と申します
私がやってるフォトジャーナリストという仕事おそらくたくさんの方にとって馴染みの
ない仕事なんじゃないかなというふうに思うんですがいかがでしょうか
先ほど在校生が半分ぐらいというふうに手を挙げていただいたのでちょっと希望を持っ
て将来この仕事につきたい人を剥いゼロですねありがとうございます
絶滅危惧種と言われているこの仕事なんですけれども
簡単に言うと写真を通して
今世界の中でそして日本の中で何が起こっているのかというのを伝えていく仕事です
様々な媒体に写真記事を配信するというのが主だった仕事になっています
今日のテーマはなぜ現場に足を運ぶのかということ
特にこの3年間特に中東方面で
同じ業種の人人たちジャーナリストたちが犠牲になるということが相次ぎました
そのために私たち問い直すことになれますなぜ
現場に足を運ぶ必要があるのか
そして伝える仕事の意味っていうのはいったい何なのかということです
皆さんはシリアという国の名前を聞いてどんなことを思い浮かべるでしょうか
今年に入って特に頻繁にニュースの中で耳にした国の名前かと思います
あの2011年の3月東日本大震災が起こったほぼ時を同じくして
シリアの町赤いバクバクでか困っているのがシリアです
南部の街ダラーという町で大規模な反政府デモが起こります
その上にがあっという間に全国に広がって内戦に入っ
今シリアの中で国内あるいは国外に逃れている人たちの数というのが1000万人を
超えたというふうに言われています
ちなみにシリアの全人口皆さんどれくらいかご存知でしょうか
シェアの全人口は2000万人強と言われています
そのおよそ半数近くが国内あるいは国外に逃れていることになります
こうしてすっかり線次洗浄というイメージが強くなってしまったこのシリアという国
実は私自身2009年まで
在庫勢の皆さんと同じくらい大学時代
この国に通い続けていましたこのシリアという国
私が足を運んだ国の中で最も美しかった国だっていうふうに思っています
ここで皆さんに少しだけ戦争前の映像をご覧になっていただきたいと思います
まずこちらの写真ファミディアと呼ばれている市バー
実は首都のダマスカスは旧市街地自体が世界遺産に登録をされていました
街の至るところにこうしてシルクロードの時代がよみがえってきたかのような風景が
広がってました
そしてそこを超えて
歌詞音サウンド呼ばれる山から首都ダマスカスを一望した風景です
そしてオレンジ色の光が土壁をぼーっと照らし出していく風景は何度見ても絶景でした
そしてこれが夜になると
こうして宝石箱をひっくり返したみたいな夜景に帰っていきます緑色にボワーっと
見えるのがモスクと言って皆さんは仮になるでしょうか
伊豆ラムの人たちが祈りを捧げる場所モスクの光です
これがかわいらしい子どもたち
私がよく滞在していた集落でいつもで迎えてくれた子ども達です
あの美しかった風景って今どうなってるんだろう
あの時出会った子どもたち今何してるんだろう
あれから思いをさせなかった日はなかったんじゃないかなと思っています
おととし2013年から
青い花米でか困っています南側の隣国ヨルダンという国でシリア難民の取材を始めてい
ます
ここに逃れてきている流入してきている難民の人たちの数というのが100万人を超え
たって言われています
ちなみによるじゃんがぁの人口皆さんどれくらいかご存知でしょうか
ヨルダンの全人口はおよそ600万人強です
およそ7人に1人がシリア難民ということになります
そのヨルダンの北部にある最大の難民キャンプ
ザータリ難民キャンプという場所
ここでの人口8万人を超えています
ちなみに難民キャンプをしっかりと運営することができる
人口の限界みなさんどれくらいかご存知でしょうか
難民キャンプを適正入営することができる人工の限界というのはせいぜい2万人と言わ
れています
1周約15キロほどの小さな敷地の中でその4倍を超える人々が7三宅あって暮らして
いることになります
砂地の真ん中に作られてしまったこのザアタリ難民キャンプ
夕方になるとこうしてワーッと一面を砂埃が追っていきます
今ここで暮らしている子どもたちの肺の疾患が深刻化しているというふうに言われてい
ます
この図あたりラーメンキャンプの中で
じゅあーなちゃんという4歳の女の子に出会います
親戚の中ぽつんと立った一人で預けられているじゃあなちゃん
彼女のお母さんそして上にいた3人の兄弟たちは
彼女の目の前で戦車の砲撃に巻き込まれて吹き飛ばされて言ってしまったそうです
お父さんとは滝時電話でお話できるんだっ
寂しそうに笑っている子はなちゃん
駅残ったお父さんはこのザアタリ難民キャンプから遠く離れて
首都アンマンの療養施設で治療を続けていました
バアシルさんと言います34歳のお父さん
あの時どうして
家族全員吹き飛ばしてくれなかったんだろう
あの時通して家族みんなまとめて殺してくれなかったんだろう
私には返す言葉がありませんでした
このヨルダンの首都アンマンの病院で同じく
アブドラ君という5歳の男の子が入院生活を送っていました
バアシルさんの鯉彼と同じように戦車の砲撃に巻き込まれていて
頭には無数のしずつ跡がありましたアブドラくんって呼びかけても反応はなくて
中の移転を見つめたまま
手を握っても握り返さない
次に会いに行った時にアブドラ9お母さんと一緒にヘナをする事が出来てました
私はその最初に撮らせてもらった写真をお母さんのところに持って行きました
シリア側からも散らせる思い出の品というのはほとんどなかったそうです
ありがとう
今度はこのアブドラが元気になって
外で走りも当てる予想写真撮りに来てちょうだいねえっ
お母さん嬉しそうでした
そして私が滞在中最後に会った時
アブドラ君こうして初めて上半身を起こしてくれて
本当にわずかなんですけれども手を振ってくれて
握った手を始めて握り返してくれました
あの時の手の温かさっていうのを今でも忘れることができずにいます
あもしかしたら元気になって
ちょっと走り回っていラブドラッグの写真を撮れる放って近いかもしれない
この時希望を持って帰国をしました
そしてその夢は
二度と叶うことがなくなってしまいました
私が帰国をしてわずかに1週間後のことでした
4台が急変
また小さな小さな命がここで一つ消えていくことになります
こんな時に
いつもいつも自分たちの仕事の価値を疑うことになります
写真という集団とても間接的な手段です
写真を使って直接目の前の人の命を救うということができないからです
先ほど在校生の方に手をあげていただきましたが
もしも私が皆さんくらいの時に医者になるっていう選択をしてたら
vetra 詳しのなかったかもしれないし
もしも私が皆さんぐらいの時に ngo で働くっていう選択をしてたら
残されてしまった家族や他の子供たちに寄り添って活動し続けることができるのに
皆さんだったらどんな風に捉えるでしょうか
この時に現地の ngo の方にいただいた言葉を今でも思い出すようにしてます
夏樹さんこれは役割分担なんです
僕たち ngo 職員はここで子どもたち残された人たちに寄り添って活動することが
できるかもしれないだけどここで何が起こっているのかっていうのを世界に発信する
って言うことができない
あなたは少なくとも通い続けることはできるし
ここで何が起こっているのかっていうのを世界に発信することができるからだから役割
分担なんです
一人の人間が全部の役割を果たすってことはできないかもしれないだけどそれぞれが
できることを持ち寄ったら何か乗り越えられるものがあるかもしれない
今年の2015年2月の1日
あまりにも悲しいニュースが早朝日本にも入り込んでくることになります
その日のうちねぇよる谷とこうしてこの翌日
2月の2日
ヨルダンの首都アンマンの日本大使館の前に100人を超える
ヨルダンが人たちが集いました
日本の友人達のために祈りましょう
ことを健二さんそして湯川遥菜さんのために基本にゆかりのある人たちが中心になって
追悼集会を開いてくれました
ゆる団の人たちだけではありませんあのザアタリ難民キャンプの中で何度
温かい言葉をいただいたかわかりません
あるシリア人の医師が私にこんな言葉をかけてくれました
おふたりのことは本当に残念でしたね
僕は賢治さんがのイスラム国の領域に行く前に残してくれたメッセージとても感謝して
いるんです
自分の身に何が起きてもシリアの人達を責めないでください彼そう言ってくれましたね
僕たちシリア人は彼ら2人とともにあります
彼ら彼女たちの国では友達であったり親戚を殺されたことがない人などいないぐらい
毎日毎日殺戮が続いてます
それでもこうして彼らは国境を越えて国籍を越えて私たちのために祈りを捧げてくれる
それと同じぐらい私たちは彼等彼女ためなったたちのための平和に祈ることができてた
んだろうか
大きな大きな宿題を持ち帰ってきたって思っています
同じ2月
あのザアタリ難民キャンプにバーシルさんがいったんの治療を終えてじ花ちゃんのもと
に戻ってきました
終わりの見えない難民生活かもしれない
それでも耐え抜くことができているのはこうして心から守りたいものを持っているから
でした
あの人質事件のことが報道の中で消えていったとしても彼ら彼女たちの避難生活は続け
ていきます
そんな彼らの元に私たちがどうして足を運ぶ必要があるのか
私たちの仕事を称賛したいと思ったりはしませんただ彼ら彼女たちの苦しみというのは
決して
数字で伝わり着るものではないというふうに感じてきました
社会の中で抱えられている問題というのは残念ながらたくさんの人に認識をされない
限り問題として扱われることがありません
ただその問題を抱えている当事者例えばバーシルパー知る3であったり
じゃあなちゃアブドラ君たちは自分から声を出すことができない立場にあることが
ほとんどです
その声一つ一つを届け続けることそして問題を問題にしていくこと
それが私たち伝える仕事をしている人間たちが持ち寄れる
ただ一つの役割だと思っています
皆さんはこれからどんなことに対してどんな役割を持ち寄っていきたいというふうに
思っているでしょうか
最後は
あのザアタリ難民キャンプの中で子供たちが書いてくれた得て終わりにしたいと思い
ます
彼ら彼女たちが暮らしていた美しかった故郷の街
ダラーという街です
彼ら彼女たちが1日も早くこの美しかった呼吸を取り戻すということを願って
今日のお話を終えたいと思います
最後までご清聴いただきましてありがとうございました